so i've just bumped into these two uh
young ladies and you're both ukrainian
and you actually have been renting this
apartment on the second floor there for
the last three years
but you weren't here thank god when this
missile attack happened where were you
we actually been with our parents
staying in rivena city and we were woken
up by the alarm
so uh you know this like a yak system
they send you alarm if something happens
to your apartment and there was like
fire fire fire and then um what is that
moment like when you you see your phone
and it's getting firefighter and you
know that's your home for us it was like
oh my god not again because you know
there was the first uh
actually there were three attacks in
this very region of kiev and the second
one destroyed this house
and killed one woman and
um on the first time our windows were
like you know they've fallen out so when
we woke up
first time we already had that alarm and
we understood that that was an explosion
here but we didn't assume it could be
that bad but if you've been here that
day you might have been killed
yeah i mean you know hopefully we're
like so if we you know we're hiding um
you know in the back of the apartment in
the back of the apartment probably it we
would be safe but you know we've seen
that the doors in our apartment they
were pushed out pushed out with their
explosion away so how old are you both
22 23. i mean i can't even imagine what
it must be like for you know young
people living in what was a very free
democratic country country amazing city
amazing city beautiful architecture and
then suddenly you're attacked
by russia and this is now the new normal
for you what's it like for you it's
devastating you know we sometimes do not
believe that we live in this
circumstances you know yesterday we
spent the whole day in kiev2 and we're
walking seeing those sights people and
then we hear the air raid siren and
you're like okay let's go hide and this
is like it's overwhelming it's and it's
not fair actually it feels like
someone is taking your life and you
cannot control you cannot plan anything
literally we've done like this period of
our lives like 22 23 years old it's when
you actually start everything start
planning start doing building the future
every whole life ahead of you yes and
then at any moment you could be it could
be taken yeah but we feel like we cannot
plan anything because we don't know what
we can do tomorrow where can we stay
tomorrow will we
will we rent an apartment will it be
bombed can we stay with therapy when you
when you hear those alarms because i
heard two this morning i was in my
hotels only a mile and a half away and
when i heard it it does make you feel
tense because you're not sure
what it means does that mean there's an
attack happening obviously most of them
turn out to be false alarms
alarms because it's actually alarms that
something in the air and there are other
regions of ukraine that are but that are
bombed at the same moment they're not
false alarms no they're not so this is
happening somewhere else yeah yeah it's
for sure that is something happening
something happening you're like sitting
and thinking what is gonna be here or in
other region and when you when you were
in kiev and other reject region is
bombed it's not yeah you're thinking
about your friends your family who might
get bumped any minute so yeah have you
lost any loved ones in the war so far uh
thanks god no thanks god no but you know
a lot of our close friends like really
close friends are fighting right right
yeah yeah yeah
yes yes and how old are they
like we are yeah they're the same age 22
are they professional soldiers
they volunteered and joined the armed
forces of ukraine these are good friends
of yours yes it's very very close how do
you feel about that
actually very very difficult because
every day you were texting them and
asking are you alive and when they don't
answer for like four forty four forty
eight hours and you're like you know all
these ideas going through your head
what's happening and what's going on
kind of kind of hard yeah it must be it
must be
awful
it it's you know it's like see i can see
yeah sorry well i i'm not surprised
it must be heart-rending these are
friends of yours on the front line who
are not soldiers they've just they're
fighting for their country and their
freedom right and your freedom actually
they're fighting for us being here in
tokyo right now because if we should be
thankful for them and that's the reason
we're doing everything we can do and
donating and volunteering and everything
we can do little by little in order to
at least be somehow helpful for them as
is human nature
the world is no longer as focused on
ukraine as maybe it was several months
ago yeah but but it needs to be the
fighting hasn't got less it's got more
yeah what is your message to the world
if they're watching this
start caring
we're fighting not only for freedom of
ukraine but for the freedom of europe
for the freedom of the democracy and the
rule of law and everything
and actually we think you cannot
resonate with us you cannot feel the
same definitely but if you just imagine
that any minute even now it can happen
to you maybe maybe it it will give some
more perspective yeah we know in london
obviously in world war ii we had the
blitz yes yes we had german bombers
coming over doing this to our to our
building so
londoners with long memories who who are
elderly they remember this happening in
my capital city but the idea of it
happening now in 2022 in a european city
is just an extraordinary thing that this
is happening again yeah yes
when we were told like the word might
happen this full invasion might happen
we did not believe it on the 23rd um of
february we were just talking like no
everything's gonna be fine we were here
yes so and we were woken up at 5am uh
explosions
around the city and like what's
happening and then we start checking and
they're like yeah they're full and
terrifying terrifying when that convoy
was coming into you know nearer nearer
to kiev i remember watching that and
thinking what must it be like to be in
keeve
and seeing the television pictures of
this thing coming towards you 40 miles
long you even do not understand you also
like
scary and do not know what to do and the
thing is that
russia is doing this not only to get the
territories i don't know with all the
reason they're
like thinking and
the the main thing that this is a
terrorist state and they're
just killing our homes so it's like 9 11
happening all over again every week yeah
what what do you feel about vladimir
putin i don't think there's a word that
can describe
this feeling like hatred
like
uh we do not consider him a human human
being i don't think he considers
ukrainians to be human beings i don't
think he cares does he like
does he care about anything
in the world yeah
he doesn't care about russian people i
don't want it as well yeah i don't it
might sound weird for me but he's a
psychopath
a ruling a whole country of people who
support him
yeah it's not only like his fault and we
do consider that that is a war not
between
putin and ukraine and ukraine a lot of
people in his country support him and
that also speaks a lot well they believe
he's you know repressing
nazis and fascists yes helping the
ukrainian people but we should say that
he says he's liberating you it's and you
know at some point you're like it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous we've been
living we've been having like amazing
life with the democracy in our country
with a lot of future we stayed here yes
like we didn't go to study abroad we
stayed we decided to say in ukraine
because that's our country this is the
only country i know and this is the only
country i want to live in when we look
on from the uk and other countries the
spirit of ukrainian people the
resilience the will to win
the will to repel the russians because
it's quite extraordinary where do you
where do you get this from that's not a
lot yeah it's our nature because that's
our home and i
actually every day i'm wondering with
these people who are fighting with our
country and i even wake up and think
why
are we so strong how how how how how it
happens yes but probably this because
our ancestors they did the same for us
yes so we have to do this for ourselves
what do you think of your president
zelinski
actually we are
we're proud of him and we are proud of
how he's actually holding the whole he
communicates to the whole yes how he
unites the country and he how he talks
to people abroad i heard him speak
yesterday it's magnetized
well he has a power of his rhetoric and
it reminds british people of winston
churchill in world war ii yes
just through the strength of his
communication yeah he can rally the
country we have to say that he actually
represents our feelings not vice versa
we're not like standing behind of him he
is representing our thoughts so that's
probably the main idea why is he so
powerful because he represents the whole
country some people think ukraine should
just let the russians take oh no no no
no no no no no way no we paid like
too high price for this too many people
have died for freedom so we cannot let
them down right now so it is it depends
on us yeah do you think you'll win i
don't know we're sure yes definitely
i wish you all the very best of luck
thank you i really do we're all right
behind you thank you so much
to come here and hear your stories is is
very moving thank you yeah and i'm so
sorry you've got to go through i have
three sons in my 20s a young daughter
younger than you but i can't even
imagine them being suddenly
enlisted to go and fight for their
country you know i heard about these
stories in world war ii but you just
don't imagine it in this day and age and
the fact you have these good friends
in their early 20s who've never had to
fire a gun and anger and they're now on
the front line risking their lives yeah
for all of us is is an amazing thing
yeah yeah thank you that's the only
thing we can say best of luck to you
thank you
so that was a very unexpected and very
moving interview with these two young
ukrainian women
particularly about their friends you
know who weren't soldiers and they've
been enlisted and gone off to risk their
lives and that could see the emotion on
their faces talking about their friends
but they live in this apartment which is
the second floor for the boarded up
windows and the dangling air
conditioning
machine and you've got to think if
they've been here that day and they they
were
possibly going to be here then luckily
we're out of town if they'd been there
would they survived maybe not
other people were killed in that attack
so
i thought that really brought it home
actually
what it's like for these particular
young ukrainians i mean i thought when
she said
that they can't plan for anything
they can't plan for anything in their
lives
because how can you you may not be alive
next week
absolutely desperate situation but wow
the spirit and the resilience
extraordinary people
[Music]
it's been pointed out to me just now
that there is some interesting lettering
on one of these boarded up
apartment windows here and it's very
specific so each of those are ukrainian
letters which represent ukrainian words
and the ukrainian words are putin go for
yourself
[Music]
you